Toyota let's go places is one of the
world's largest car companies but the
Toyota Motor Corporation started in 1926
as a textile loom company it soon turned
its sights to building a better
automobile the company has built cars
for more than 80 years now Toyota is
rethinking what it will take to get
through the next 80 years its new focus
is creating a world where mobility
issues of all kinds are overcome using
artificial intelligence and robots but
Toyota is not alone with car sales down
in 2017 automakers and tech companies
like Tesla alphabet Ford and Toyota are
reimagining everything from how we move
through cities to how we get around our
homes they're shaking up the auto
industry by taking on public
transportation ride-sharing and
self-driving cars Toyota which sponsors
our green room every morning put aside 1
billion dollars last year to create the
Toyota Research Institute its CEO Gil
Pratt is leading the charge to a new
frontier and transportation good morning
morning good morning so tell us what the
new frontier will be like well we are
working on several different things one
is making cars safer the other one is
more accessible and then finally most
more convenient and even more important
than that we're thinking about what's
next for Toyota how do we bring
technology that is used for mobility in
the streets into mobility within the
home particularly for aging Society Elon
Musk has estimated that almost every car
will be autonomous by 2027 I think it is
what's your estimate I don't know if
that date is correct we are coming out
with something we call the highway
teammate in 2020 and that's going to
allow for autonomous driving on the
highway and we're coming out with an
urban teammate for within cities a few
years after that so self-driving cars we
have to say Gil there come and get ready
for it all the cranky Yankees that are
afraid or the people that are worried
about it you're just saying relax
because it's coming but you have options
for us do you not that's absolutely
right so we think that automated cars
are going to be coming but we think
about it in two ways one is what we call
chauffeur mode letting the car drive for
you when either you can't drive or you
don't want to drive the other one which
we think is going to come even sooner is
Guardian mode and what Guardian is as a
safety net underneath of the driver the
driver continues to drive the car has
lots of fun driving the car and it
prevents you from having an accident has
China set a date for phasing out fossil
fuel driven cars I think that that's
true but the Toyota Research Institute
actually works mostly on AI not on
different types of fuels so what's
standing in the way of self-driving cars
is using it well there's some
technological barriers that we have a
self-driving car uses perception it uses
prediction to figure out where other
people are going to go and then it uses
planning to figure out where it should
go the first and the last layer of that
sandwich the perception and the planning
are actually pretty well in hand
predictions the hard part how do we
figure out what other people are going
to do help us understand why you all in
this industry think it's safer Elon must
certainly does - well people of course
get tired so they get drowsy people get
distracted and sometimes people get
drunk as well and that plus causes
relatively a tenfold increase in the
number of accidents and so we think that
if we have automated systems they can
see better than people and of course
they don't get drowsy or just distracted
and they certainly don't get drunk and
they drive at the speed limit they well
that's an interesting question it may be
that the safest speed to go is the
median speed of the cars around you and
it's still yet to be worked out along
with the government exactly what that
speech should be managed people of
course drive a little faster than the
speed limit that's a current issue that
needs okay you know what's really
interesting to me is how you're looking
at this self-driving technology - what
you call human autonomy so how will this
apply to our human activity yeah so I
think that that's most important toyota
cares about people most of all when I
went to interview there to get my job
they talked to me mostly about love and
how the relationship between a person
and a car is different than the
relationship with between a person and a
refrigerator people love their car a
second
they tend not to love their
refrigerators and so what is the
difference and and the difference is
that a car enables human autonomy it's
not really about autonomous cars it's
about the autonomy of people and we
think we can extend that beyond cars to
robotics as well particularly as the
baby boom hits in the US and we have
many people who are trying to age in
place within home we think a lot of that
technology can be used to help people to
leave a better life you're doing cool
things with robots too so you unhook
your refrigerator I love my car yeah
Gill Pratt it's so nice to talk to you
thank you so much for joining us we
appreciate it very nice to be here thank
you very much